chad starts off this hour in minneapolis
hi
chad welcome to the ramsey show
yeah thanks for taking my call dave and
chrissy
so a little backstory separated in
divorce in 2020
was able to you know contribute to all
the bills through the divorce
late last year and was able to pay off
uh 30 grand in debt
and actually paid off my all of the
balance of my student loan seven
thousand dollars this morning
so i'm officially debt free good for you
that's awesome
wow yeah so
2020 was was rough but we got through
some stuff um
so my my situation is i am currently
living in a home
owned by my by my company for
free it's a great place i just cover
utilities i'm sort of a pseudo caretaker
of the house
with no with no plan to need to move off
of that
through the divorce uh i gained sole
possession of a rental
that we used to live in we only lived
there for about a year about seven years
ago
so i'm aware of that you know there's
probably
probably some long-term capital gains
tax um on that
i owe 45 it's worth about 105 so
capital gains on that i think is 20 of
about 12 or so 12 000
to i've got
i've got a great renter in there it's
actually my ex-wife's family
who's living in that house and looking
at
with where real estate is now me not
needing a place to live
doesn't make sense to sell the house pay
the tax put that money that i would make
on that
into the market so that i have money for
a down payment in the future
wow there's a lot of crap going on there
[Laughter]
all right uh uh yeah i mean it to me
it's actually moronic to say my
ex-wife's
in-laws are living in it and they're
great renters these things all right i
was in the same breath he said that the
same breath
and it's my ex-wife okay okay great
what's your definition of a great renter
they pay
they pay they're clean um i'm guessing
you have a good relationship
sort of good relationship even even even
even through the even through the
divorce
um her myself and my
and my ex-wife family uh we still get
along really well
so it wasn't it wasn't like this
terrible this
this you know back and forth divorce you
know we developed
a nice guy like that so he's a nice guy
this is i mean
this is great that's good i'm happy
that's okay yeah that's good we're
shocked we're shocked chad but it's good
it's good there's nothing wrong with it
it's a good shot so
you don't have a home uh that you live
in because your company that you work
for
furnishes you one you're 100 debt free
you have your emergency fund in place or
we'll have shortly what is your income
uh 105. okay plus a plus a
a a hot or cold
uh bonus annually in february okay got
one this year but
but so generally speaking set aside the
whole drama of the divorce and the
in-laws and all that stuff
and just say okay we have a rental
property that we owe 45 000 bucks on
do i sell it uh i don't know why you
would
well so the looking at you know let's
just say
three years old so i'm i'm tired of that
company
if i were ever to if you ever needed a
house and you wanted to take the money
out of that house you could just sell it
then
right so what's the why why why sell it
now
well to because it's it's i don't know
that the house is ever going to be worth
more
and why wouldn't i could i and
well i'll be this with with the market
that that i'm that i'm in
it's a it's a rural town um only about
500 people
um houses don't fly off the shelves um
and i'm just looking at
would i make a better return on my money
is it an area of the city that is
blighted
i mean if you you wouldn't buy this
piece of real estate as an investment
were you buying real estate today
um it i it's not a it's not a great um
area for buying buying real estate
as an investment why
i don't know maybe i guess maybe it is i
i i bought it on a foreclosure
uh that's not the point what i could do
why why
you made a clear statement wise it's
possible that your statement's correct i
wasn't saying you're wrong i'm just
understanding why you're just saying
it's so rural
like it's no it's a row house in inner
city house right oh
no no no it's not an inner city it's
it's a rural rural
misunderstanding there are 500 people in
the town so small town people are not
moving there
it's hard to move i get it only only
only only 500 people in town
oh with with no you know we're we're the
closest large city is minneapolis but
yeah i probably would not buy that as a
regular one
i wouldn't disagree with you driving 20
minutes to go to
walmart yeah there's not a vibrant
enough market for it to increase a lot
in value is what you're saying because
the market's not very big
so that's why you wouldn't that's why
you wouldn't buy it again okay
right so when is their lease up
so through i currently do not have a
lease with them
so it's we've just been kind of poking
along at it
what do they pay in rent 700
is that market uh yeah that's that's
market
okay the mortgage the mortgage on it is
is
um okay well you know we got to take the
whole thing into consideration
i'm not worried about the in-laws
because you're not ex-in-laws because
you're not
so uh but if with a standard tenant in
there
or with them i'm going to offer them a
slight discount
on the rent to stay in the property with
a 30-day notice
to leave which is what they have now and
because they don't have a lease and the
discount is to keep the property
sparkling clean
and show ready because we're putting it
on the market
if they don't want the property to be
shown and they won't keep it sparkling
clean
for a slight discount in the rent and
continue with the 30-day notice promise
then they need to go ahead and leave and
you need to put it on the market
right
yeah i think i i think that's more so i
just wanted it yeah now how to couch
that in a conversation where it doesn't
feel like you're hitting back from the
divorce is an interesting
discussion too right right
right yeah and that that's that's the
delicate balance is that
you know great
so it's also it's also okay to wait a
fall to do this and let this
all get a little more water under the
bridge
if you want to be nice to it if you want
to be super nice too right well
yeah so i mean but there's
you don't need the money and there's no
rush no i don't
don't don't need the money it's but but
looking at could if i
if that money was in in a mutual fund
could i be looking at
ten percent because i'm not you know
obviously the longer they stay in the
rental the more
principal that's it's completely okay to
move them now but the closer to the
divorce you move the more they're going
to interpret that as hitting back
regardless of what you say because human
beings are just going to act that way
i think do you think yeah i think it
just yeah the the timing and the way
that you present it is going to matter a
lot yeah
and uh but there's no even what you
would make on it is there oh and by the
way your capital gains calculations
wrong you need to talk to your tax guy
it's not based on the equity in the
house it's based on
what you paid for it minus the
depreciation you've taken which is your
adjusted basis subtracting from your
sale price what you owe on it has
nothing to do with the calculation